yeah welcome to this video playing and
raggedy again and let's see how it
proceeds this time see 6mm gather c65
line probably yeah I don't know f 493
both quite good
yeah h3 is designed to prevent Bishop g4
not allowing the exchange and yeah some
uncommon but nevertheless playable yeah
I wonder if this is really helping him
this Bishop Bishop d5 I play c4 and it's
really bad and so it probably needs to
retreat and then what our k h6 self he
wants to play age 6 mm
see Thor mmm so c 4 h 6 takes on d5
takes on g5
yeah this is some probably quite good ok
so I won't do that I should have thought
about this bit longer Bishop g5 c4h
sixes it's not great for me let's just
drop this back it's not nothing bad
really happened i just lost a nice
smooth
yeah it's um probably about equal
position I can I think developed on with
Bishop f4 Queenie to something like that
he is very very nicely developed as well
i just got an extra point in the center
maybe yeah probably black assam already
a bit a bit for choice IAM so not it's
not terrible for white but it's a it
looks like it's easier to play for black
okay how to proceed 22 yeah maybe yeah
95
of course Bishop f4 is what I'd like to
play but I cannot manage maybe I need to
do that
yeah we can probably play up to 80 also
97 trying to get rid of this this night
yeah the question is is Bishop performs
he maybe it's may be able to play g5
Abbott this is really a weakening with
probably okay he can play just just
going to be six though
what if I do that intending h5 not so
maybe this is bad but nike phone no it's
not not good I can just take it yeah h5
is something he needs to attend to i
think don't think you can ignore it
maybe just six yeah or this one it's a
tactical the tactical try
check
yeah complicated position now I don't
think I'm in bad shape actually so it's
pretty complicated and the skin has got
some some issues as well every Queen g4
I would be great Queen g43 in an ideal
world I'll manage to play that now
probably will play five he doesn't okay
I thought this was really a threat with
queen of five maybe it is not just maybe
it isn't a threat i don't know but now
he cannot play you five and I'm
threatening Bishop b5 I believe plus
rookie 3 p-5 the whole it's really not
defending this at all I mean hmm is it
so harmless
when first is now Bishop f5 f6 group g3
and resigns let's see what is doing
against that this one
yeah should be age six is still
threatened
careful okay shade very annoying
ah I miss playing that and this was for
sure very good for white very sure about
that check
time warning
yes guys hard to beat I mean is he's not
playing really well to be honest but
he's defending very precisely
huh yeah that probably wasn't so easy
but had something Jack pretty clear now
I can just take you three come on my
hands yeah round here why dyslexia
chickens absolutely no no question so
what is winning here you should be far
as winning as the first one okay Wow
okay this didn't didn't cross my mind at
all it just rinse the exchange for
nothing check so be sure before I cannot
take this is this is just meet next move
and this wins the exchange I didn't see
it not at all all right but this doesn't
look too bad yeah this is very precise
there should be six is probably the only
move they get the only move yeah auntie
I'm losing the threat losing 30 m yeah
my original idea was this threatening
rookie six but he can't play work g8 and
after that check there's this problem
the safe zone this we do otherwise
rookie one wins simple so I cannot do
that and this means it's it's tricky
very tricky already I only had this
Bishop a phone really cool yeah and I
didn't see that age 54 saying okay but
here it's probably a unclear okay I
didn't check didn't really calculate
here just gambling with brookie five
yeah Queen a4a Bishop a for this was the
only spot ruling yeah this is the issue
with so with those very strong players
they sometimes really play play badly
and it happens but if they do they
recognize the point where they need to
play only moves and then they they find
them rocky this was really just bad play
but after that after a Miss Bishop a for
everything's perfect now he plays Bishop
e6 the only move otherwise I won't be
should be five group g3 and this again
the only move it's okay it's not so
difficult but Luke g8 it's a rookie six
is not working the exchange sack and
where you are here I'm yeah I'm just
fishing here with with them no real
playing a concept anymore this is also
very difficult now to claim what what's
pieces are bit loose this isn't so bad I
mean it's a material that's equal and
it's there's no big reason why blood why
black should be better but okay I
couldn't I couldn't really find any any
concept here anymore with them with the
the way the game the game went yeah
interesting fried nevertheless thanks
for watching